"Let's start with the end
of the world, why don't we?
Get it over with and move on
to more interesting things."
Those first two sentences
introduce the fact
that the end of the
world is happening,
which I think of as a really
important inciting incident.
You aren't stuck in the past
when you're writing fantasy.
You aren't stuck in space when
you're writing science fiction.
A lot of the things
that we traditionally
think of as science fiction
are actually fantasy.
For example, "Star Wars."
What's the force?
You can call it magic.
It's space magic.
In this MasterClass, we'll talk
about how to develop characters
that are interesting.
People are 3-dimensional,
people are contradictory.
I'll be using my own
techniques derived
from psychology and my own
background as a psychologist.
We're going to actually start
going through an exercise where
we build a world from the planet
level on down to the people.
We will talk about how to
become a professional writer.
If you work and hone your craft,
you will eventually break in.
When I was small, I
would go to the library
and I would ask the librarians
to recommend science fiction
books.
They would recommend the
big well-known names.
The problem with this is,
as a young Black girl,
reading a bunch
of novels written
by a bunch of
middle-aged white dudes,
there wasn't a whole
lot in those stories
that was speaking to me.
If you, like me, are
a marginalized writer,
you're going to
encounter some bigotry.
There are people out there
who need your example, who
need you to go forth
and fight that battle,
so they won't have
to fight as hard.
And it's worth it.
You help to change the
profession by your existence.
I'm N. K. Jemisin, and
this is my MasterClass.